yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing a roomie lifts right okay
place the sidelines against the coins
and I'm going to respond with a sideline
I guess they're somewhat weird variation
but my interesting let's see what he
does
the capture hang yeah it seems he wants
to cheat on c6 en disposition may be
also 95 but I don't know that is so
dangerous I always have Queen to d6
I don't think Bishop takes c6 is all
that much of a problem it's an isolated
double pawn but it's also a good butcher
come on c8 maybe I could have actually
taken on c3 and played something like 25
and nobody takes himself interesting
yeah ro but it just gives me really nice
Bishop air
okay so that looks like a good
positioner but what happens here
Bishop you have to get this Bishop
developed with this long diagonal that's
not so easy I think I'm just going to
fianchetto this Bishop as well must be a
good position there on the long diagonal
maybe he wants to play I thought like b3
and so on but okay I think I'm just
going to centralize one look to the
eight one two dat and we should be five
might be something yeah
[Music]
five and a four something like that or
or just completely we are completely
centralizing certainly okay he cannot
move the night a minute sir not not easy
to play for him
yeah I wonder if he find a four is
actually good on we also play more prep
moves I mean white does not have much
active play going for him anyway
[Music]
well
okay now I don't understand them
[Music]
okay efore is the simple and good
solution just open the position up even
more f5 is also quite good
that okay let's let's keep it simple I
would also always have a very good
ending here if I don't find anything
better
[Music]
to trading trading this as well as a bit
lame and I know I don't quite see how to
continue on after it it's candy 27 is
somewhat annoying I think maybe I just
go back
we're not quite sure how to make
progress one thing could be to use this
Bishop on b7 to attack the pawns like c5
and just try to get this Bishop around
to the pawns just play an ending
[Music]
I could gain even more space there was
g5
which would be 8 something I should
reform putting it on the diagonal maybe
going to be 7 then
will I have to be careful in there
Bishop might take my pawns
I wonder what he is calculating here
actually what is the big point here ship
should be eight indeed okay so put this
only four as planned that covers this
diagonal and Queen to be 7s potential
moves
[Music]
we shove a 7 I have Bishop takes f3
intermediate move
okay so I mean I cannot do all that much
cheap takes their can't so let's remove
it clean several he can take some
definitely not
[Music]
time warning king of 1726 Oh boss I will
definitely trade which can check first
then go 22 check
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now it's close to two phone
[Music]
to
[Music]
I get to see three I don't need to take
anything in place very gently
yeah that was a pretty nice position
after year they basically decided to
suffer the whole game when you took on
c6 which was a bit mysterious or took on
d5 to conceive six so let's have a look
yeah here what the engine gives us
actually making quite some sense take
and play Queen d5
I only saw that after I played g6 so
that that is quite nicely I'm attacking
this and this is definitely a completely
fine position okay so here yeah so here
I am
why not just play a normal move like
group e1 or something or deform that
that must be fine but specially I'm like
it's just substantially better for from
nothing basically I thought you would
try rookie won't at least try to whoops
I'm sorry try to make make a feeling a
bit more difficult but okay yeah this is
a very comfortable position yeah f5 as
suggested by the computers of course
also making lots of sense you're just
grabbing as much space as possible and
try to combine this with an attack on
the king like f4 and then d4 that that's
actually interesting idea I played in a
more technical way like you okay
super super save you can never play this
and because I take and then pin yeah
this is just just a bit better or
forever and ever and ever
okay I could have taken one g2 oh I
didn't see that
simple but this just keeps all the
advantages I didn't want to trade I know
that the bishop looks bad on g7 but you
can always we look at why a d6 it's not
a big deal so it's got really really bad
when he played this I mean after this
the games lost him basically lost like I
just get to play against those pawns and
he cannot attack mine check check
get here it's basically a super-funny
he cannot move the Knights and after
this he will lose everything I can also
just take behind but there's no media
he's running out of moves yes we played
this at some point and then d2 is
unstoppable
oh yes two sec the night you get he gave
me a very nice position with the capture
on c64 um we had no particular benefit
okay guys thanks for watching